en el último vídeo hablamos de lo que
son las derivadas parciales de funciones
multi variables verdad es decir que
tuvieran varias entradas y aquí quiero
hablar de lo que son las segundas
derivadas parciales así que vamos a
escribir alguna función multi variable
digamos pensemos en esta función
fx que esto sea el seno de x por ye
cuadrada muy bien esta será nuestra
función multi variable y como vimos en
el vídeo anterior podríamos calcular dos
distintas derivadas parciales verdad
podríamos calcular la derivada con
respecto la derivada de nuestra función
con respecto a la variable x o también
podríamos calcular la derivada de esta
función con respecto a nuestra variable
y en verdad tenemos estas dos opciones
si nosotros queremos calcular la
derivada parcial de f con respecto de x
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es tener
que considerar solo la variable x
a la variable ye la vamos a considerar
como una constante
entonces si derivamos esta expresión con
respecto de x bueno tendremos que
calcular la derivada del seno de x que
es coseno de x por ye cuadrada que en
esencia es una constante para fines de
derivar con respecto de x ahora sí que
si calculamos la derivada parcial de f
con respecto de y en este caso ya será
nuestra variable y x sería constante de
esta forma el seno de x completitos
sería una constante que multiplica a ye
cuadrada entonces al derivar con
respecto de y como esto es constante se
quede igual verdad tendremos seno de x
que multiplica a la derivada de ch
cuadrada que es 2 de verdad
entonces la derivada es 2 y estas son
las primeras derivadas parciales verdad
quisiera antes hablar un poquito de otra
anotación que existe para denotar a las
derivadas parciales y es una anotación
que es bastante cómoda pero
quizás es poco intuitiva y podemos
escribir
efe con un sub índice y para denotar a
la derivada de f con respecto de y lo
mismo podríamos hacer para esta derivada
verdad pondríamos efe con un subíndice
xy esto denota la derivada parcial de f
con respecto de x entonces observemos
que las derivadas parciales son también
funciones multivariable es verdad
entonces tiene sentido hablar de las
derivadas parciales de estas derivadas
parciales que ya hemos obtenido verdad
entonces por ejemplo para esta función
nuevamente tenemos dos opciones para
calcular derivadas parciales verdad
podríamos tener la derivada parcial con
respecto de x de esta función o la
derivada parcial con respecto de y
entonces aquí tendríamos por ejemplo la
derivada parcial con respecto de x de
esta función que ya era la derivada
parcial de f con respecto
x entonces si nosotros derivamos con
respecto de x a esta expresión aquí está
nuestra variable verdad que sería cosa
de x esto sería una constante y entonces
al derivar coseno de x nos queda menos
seno de x multiplicando nuestra
constante que es ye cuadrada verdad
entonces lo mismo podríamos hacer ahora
para derivar con respecto de y nosotros
podríamos derivar ahora con respecto de
y esta expresión que ya era la derivada
parcial de f con respecto a x entonces
si nosotros calculamos esta derivada
ahora nuestra variable sería aquí está
esta parte que es de cuadrada y coseno
de x simplemente es una constante verdad
entonces aquí tendríamos coseno de x por
la derivada de ye cuadrada que es
y esta sería nuestra expresión para la
segunda derivada verdad que sería
derivar con respecto de iu a la parcial
de f con respecto de xy como en el
cálculo tradicional podríamos hacer una
especie de abuso de notación verdad
nosotros podríamos reescribir esto de
aquí como la segunda derivada verdad
como podríamos pensar como la segunda
derivada tradicional pero aquí vamos a
hablar de parciales verdad entonces
podríamos poner una segunda derivada de
f y aquí vamos a poner que derivamos con
respecto de x ambas veces verdad que en
realidad podríamos pensar que es con
respecto a x cuadrado aunque aunque esto
es un abuso de notación en realidad es
la segunda derivada de f con respecto de
x ambas veces muy bien y la verdad es
que la primera vez que aprendí de estas
cosas a mí me revolvía mucho digamos que
con la anotación de lightning es verdad
tenemos la intuición de cómo cambia efe
al variar nuestra variable verdad x por
ejemplo pero podemos perder esta
intuición al útil
esta nueva anotación al menos al menos
podemos entenderlo digamos como si fuera
un operador de verdad parecía al
respecto de equis y lo estamos usando
dos veces y de este lado por ejemplo
ahora de este lado tendremos algo algo
chistoso vamos a tener la parcial la
segunda parcial de efe y ahora hay que
decir bien cuál es el orden en el que lo
hacemos primero lo hacemos con respecto
de equis y luego derivamos con respecto
de qué bien entonces así es como se
escribe en este orden ahora bien
podríamos hacer lo mismo con esta otra
función verdad podríamos tener aquí una
derivada parcial con respecto de x
podríamos tomar la derivada parcial con
respecto de x y que es lo que
obtendríamos entonces como siempre
podríamos considerar esta parte que es 2
como una constante y simplemente
derivamos esto la de entonces la
derivada del seno de x sería coseno de x
por nuestra constante que es 2 muy bien
y algo genial que podríamos remarcar
desde este momento que al menos a mí
siempre me ha parecido increíble me ha
parecido muy sorprendente es que estos
dos resultados resultan ser iguales
verdad e incluso cuando hemos tomado
caminos distintos para llegar a estas
derivadas parciales verdad en realidad
nosotros podríamos pensarlo de esta
forma que la segunda derivada de f
verdad la parcial la segunda parcial de
f con respecto de x y luego con respecto
de ye que es lo que teníamos de este
lado es este resultado es exactamente
igual a la segunda derivada de f primero
con respecto de iu y luego con respecto
de x que es exactamente lo que hemos
calculado aquí verdad primero con
respecto de iu y luego con respecto de x
y lo que resulta ser sorprendente es que
en realidad esto es válido para una gran
cantidad de funciones de hecho este
resultado es conocido como el teorema de
swartz
que si las segundas derivadas parciales
son continuas en el punto de interés
entonces estas derivadas cruzadas son
iguales y para fines prácticos las
funciones con las que uno se topa
siempre son de este tipo y entonces el
orden de las derivadas en realidad no
importa verdad quizás algo que hay que
mencionar es otra anotación alternativa
con la que podemos trabajar por ejemplo
en esta segunda derivada de f con
respecto de x ambas veces podríamos
escribirlo mucho más simples poniendo
efe x x verdad este subíndice que nos
dice xx nos dice que derivamos respecto
de x y luego respecto de x si nosotros
queremos pensar por ejemplo en esta
derivada parcial tendríamos que escribir
efe primero x y luego ye y es que en
realidad aquí hay que invertir el orden
porque aquí lo estamos leyendo de
izquierda a derecha mientras que aquí lo
pensamos de derecha a izquierda verdad
aquí es porque así se lee y aquí es
porque lo estamos pensando como una
especie de multiplicar
verdad entonces está por ejemplo de aquí
sería la derivada primero con respecto
de ye y luego con respecto de x entonces
dicho esto creo que es un muy buen
momento para detener este vídeo nos
vemos en la próxima ocasión